So I don't know
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the book of prayer, the
chapters regarding the timings of
prayer.
And
we were discussing the three main
prohibited times for a person to pray.
And
the instances
which are considered exempted from and
and considered to be exceptions
to that those three prohib prohibited
times of prayer. And we said that
any specific prayer
that is optional
if it is specified by time, place
or occasion,
it becomes exempt from the general
prohibited times of prayer. Right?
[Silence]
And we mentioned
yesterday and the day before examples
of
optional prayers which are connected
to a particular time and we mentioned
for instance making or making optional
prayers before Jum begins and that a
person continues to pray optional
prayers until the im rises onto the me.
Okay.
So the second of these types
is
those prayers, optional prayers which
are a which are tied to a place to a
specific place
such as the prayer for the masid
which is referred to by the as
this isn't a title that is found in the
sunnah per se. It's what the scholars
and jurists of Islam used to refer to
that prayer which is made for the
occasion of entering the masjid. Now
it's important to understand something
when we look at a statement that the
prophet made saiam
such as
They said if any of you enters into the
masid then he is not to sit down
until he makes to raqa prayer.
Let's examine this narration for a
second.
What we understand from the narration at
its face value
is that
if a person enters the masid, they are
to make two raqa and that these two raqa
they are not to sit until they have made
them.
Now let me ask you a question.
How many of us today right now for this
prayer came into the masid
during the obligatory prayer
either just as the was called or as we
were already in prayer join the prayer
and we finish prayer and now we're all
seated. Did any of us get up and pray to
raka again immediately after the prayer?
The answer is no. Is that right or
wrong? No, that's correct. You'll never
find a narration
where the companions finished their
salah, got up immediately, and made two
raqa.
Why? Why didn't we make two raqa? Why?
Huh?
We already made the obligatory prayer,
correct?
Okay. The obligatory prayer was two.
Let's say it was
and we made four for or let's say it was
and we made three or four for would we
get up in that case and make two raqa
[Arabic recitation]
The answer is no. So what does that tell
us? This is correct by the way. The
companions never made those salah and
then got up and made two raqa. You'll
never find an narration that.
You'll never find the prophet himself
doing this.
Why? Because unanimously we all
understand that we've already prayed.
We've already prayed. We've already
prayed. We've already prayed.
So we don't have to pray the two. So
this means that the two raqa for
entering the masid
it doesn't have to be two raqa
those two raqa are not intended for
themselves being two raqa with the
intention of masid
the point is and the spirit of the
narration if any of you enters into the
masid he is not to sit until he prays to
the spirit Spirits of the narration is
the masid is not every other place
on earth. It is bad manners to just walk
into the masid and use it without
praying first. So make sure that you
pray first before you sit down whatever
that prayer is.
We all understood this without really
putting it into words. Right? And this
is what the scholars understand from
[Silence]
And so two, whether it be two or three
or four, the least a person can make is
two, right? So it has to be at least
two. But if it's more than that then
you've done what you have to do based on
this.
A person does not have to isolate
from other prayers. If a person comes in
let's say for and they're going to make
two
for the
right two.
Do they have to make two raqa for the
masjid and then two raqa for
separate? No, they just make two raqaud.
And that is
because that's the point of the
narration. The point of the narration is
not to treat the masid any other
building. It is sacred. And so the first
thing you do when you enter the masid is
you pray. You do what the masid was
initially built for and then after that
you may use its facilities.
This is what is intended. But in the
absence of any pressing prayer
immediately
then the least is for us to make to
correct and for this reason
in the form of is considered optional.
Some scholars have said it is
obligatory.
But the point is is that
this is a which is tied to the place.
Therefore, it is exempt
from the prohibitions. It is exempt from
the prohibition of salah
after
salah before salah after
sometimes some massages
when you come into the masid if you come
in before
it's interesting to look at
if you come into the masid
you'll find that Just before Mr. there's
many people in the masid all walking
around inside the masid inside the masid
just walking.
Have you ever seen this before? Have you
ever seen this? Have you ever seen this?
Some must. Why is this? Because
they believe that this is not
permissible to pray before you sit down.
But it's also not permissible to pray
after. So we're in a problem here. So
what do we do? We just stroll
right until the adan of is in and then
we can pray and sweet relief we can
finally sit down.
No narration ever
has this in it where the companions were
all standing up in the masjid. Why don't
you guys sit down? Well, you know, we
can't pray after also and we can't sit
down, so we're stuck in this kind of
limbo.
And so, this is where the exemptions
from prohibitions that come in.
Another exemption of place is Mecca.
that a person may that a person may pray
anytime they are in Mecca.
There is no prohibition for the time of
prayer. And this is something that we
will discuss tomorrow inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]